intel finally dropped their mobile alder
lake chips in the form of the msi raider
ge76
and it is impressive so today we're
gonna take all the info that we got from
this release today all the benchmarks
the performance and see how it stacks up
to the m1 max now this laptop isn't
gonna hit the shelves for at least a
month so we are gonna have to wait to
get our hands on it but we have a ton of
information that i sourced from
endantech we have notebook check we also
have dave lee's excellent channel so
let's go ahead and dig right in and see
can this emerald max hang in there with
this big boy now as far as price it
comes in at four
thousand
dollars this is a 17 inch machine with a
weight of six and a half pounds and it
has a crazy cooling system and this
alder lake chip needs it now as far as
the ram it has 32 gigs just like the m1
max that i tested and it has two
terabytes of ssd built in as well and as
far as the graphics we have the
ti now this is the laptop chip crazy
powerful with 16 gigs of dedicated
memory that is about twice as fast as
the other 30 series so we're gonna see
how this graphics card performs as well
now right out of the gate i have to say
that this is not a multimedia laptop for
general use this is a brick of a gaming
machine and we know that because of its
display we have a 17 inch screen that is
just 1080p compared to about 3.5 k
and as far as brightness it's only at
about 260
nits
very low brightness compared to a
standard of 500 but up to 1600 nits for
hdr color grading and as far as the
color accuracy we see that it's only 61
dc ip3 compared to almost 100 with the
macbook so uh it's not really for video
editing photo editing things like that
and the sd card that is included it's a
really slow one at about 80 megabytes a
second compared to 250 so we know that
this is just purely for convenience not
a machine that you actually want to be
doing photo or video editing on but as
far as performance with that alder lake
12 900 hk processor that can hit up to 5
gigahertz the performance is there we
have 14 cores in the cpu eight of them
are now efficiency cores just like the
macbook has but the macro only has two
and then six are high performance very
high performance cores let's start out
with geekbench five and in the single
core
the m1 pro and max ship finally gets
beat with a score of
1855 for the intel processor that is
insane single core performance now
looking at multi-core once again it gets
beat with a crazy high score of 13
428 that is higher than my intel mac pro
with 12 high performance cores that
sucks down a crazy amount of power so
this is a very impressive performance
now taking this a step further if you
max out the cpu in cinebench r23 we get
an insane score of 18
282
compared to 12 300 that is mind-blowing
performance that destroys desktops good
job intel that is crazy now in order to
achieve this performance one we have
this huge laptop with a crazy uh cooling
system they're using a liquid metal pad
that they say is 10 better than all of
the other competition out there they
have this great cooling system and it
actually has to cool up to about 120
watts of power to achieve over 18 000
score whereas our m1 max processor and
the m1 pro for its performance cores uh
well total cpu is about 30 watts so a
lot less wattage now because of that of
course you're gonna have fan noise the
macbook pro even under full load is
under 30 decibels very quiet of course
the chassis is thin whereas this msi
runs at 59 decibels and it also runs
really hot so that is
quite loud very very loud now dave lee
also tested out the balance mode and
then that brought it down to 42 decibels
still way louder
and then actually knocks the wattage
down to about 75 watts from 120. now i
do have to still give intel praise
because here the performance didn't
actually get that much lower we're at 16
597 still smoking the m1 pro and the m1
max processor so very good there now
what i'm really curious about are the
lower end cpus the i5s the ones that
have less cores that are going to go
into laptops like the new dell xps
basically how these chips these all
delay chips are going to perform in
laptops that are actually as thin and as
light as the macbook pro so if you guys
want to see that you guys want to see
head-to-head comparisons with a lot of
real-world tasks not just benchmarks
make sure you guys click that subscribe
button down below and with that you guys
can help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers and now let's talk about the
graphics card we have that 3080ti
very high performance one packed into
this system and this thing can actually
use up to 175 watts of power compared to
the m1 max's
32 cores which use up to 46 peak now
that is a huge difference in wattage
but we also have a difference in
performance using the cross platform gfx
bench we see that this graphics card
hits
327.7 fps in the aztec ruins 1440p
off-screen compared to 310.
not a really big difference there
compared to the difference in wattage
and fan noise now of course this program
is optimized for
apples silicon chips and also for metal
so this is the most fair comparison but
if you're gonna be a gaming there's very
little games that run well with apple
silicon and running on
metal as well so definitely a much
better gaming system now as far as other
tests dave lee tested out uh blender's
ev party tug and that took 3.6 seconds
compared to 5.9 so not really double the
performance but it's getting closer now
personally i want to use the new metal
optimized cycles and also the optimized
version for windows and then once we get
these machines we will be testing out
giving you guys more tests instead of
just this simple one that's running off
the ev engine
now i also looked at speedometer 2.0
which is their general web browsing
performance the m1 mo pros and mac score
277 it's an extremely high score these
machines are amazing for web browsing
super snappy and this thing got
269 fps right there along with apple
systems incredible performance much
faster than any other windows system in
the past i also have the ssd test over
here and that uses two ssds you get two
terabytes
instead of one terabyte of course that
system is 500 bucks more so you could
spend actually at two terabytes in a
similar price point but as far as the
read speed it is very close uh just
behind the macbook and right is quite a
bit slower apple's ssds are very very
quick but of course they are soldered on
now we also have a puget bench and a
video editing test with
premiere pro dave lee ran it and this
alder lake system did beat out the
macbook we're at just over 14 minutes
compared to just over 18. now of course
premiere pro isn't the best optimized i
personally am really curious about
davinci resolve
not as something that we are going to
have to test once we get it but he also
ran puget bench's overall benchmark that
doesn't just look at rendering times but
also playback performance a lot of that
with different codecs and the m1 max
still beats that out because of apple's
decoders and encoders that are built in
that makes everything very efficient and
very smooth that is in premiere pro
now let's go ahead and talk about
battery life this is the elephant in the
room now this laptop does have a 99.9
watt hour battery the biggest you can
get in order to still be able to legally
fly with this laptop so very big battery
a lot of windows laptops have 80 watts
or 65 much smaller ones but even still
and even with these efficiency cores the
macbook still kills it in terms of
battery life so for simple web browsing
use and this is in the balance mode you
can get about six hours of web browsing
with that laptop um not great not
terrible it is an improvement compared
to about 14 hours with the 16 inch
macbook pro now as far as video playback
you get about four and a half hours of
video playback
compared to about 20 on the macbook so
very very efficient the apple's uh
decoding engine barely uses any power
and then as far as video rendering if
you're doing some serious stuff you will
get about two hours with this ge 76
raider with alder lake compared to about
seven hours with the macbook now if you
don't put in the balance mode for a
simple use you will get about three
hours still so make sure you put into
the balance mode that limits the wattage
in the turbo boost now another big
improvement with these systems that
nantec talked about uh was intel's
thread director it's a new kind of
technology that automatically uh
prioritize certain workloads and
balances the system out apple macbooks
have been using this for a long time i
noticed that years ago when i would be
exporting video and then i could still
use the web browser wouldn't lock up
like my custom water cooled windows pc
that had a lot better performance so
with these new chips it will actually
give you a little bit of that
performance i'll cut back on rendering
for example so you can still use the
system still use web browsing and simple
tasks without it being all slow and
glitchy and that is a major win for
general usability with these laptops so
overall we see at least in this first
laptop this big boy that the performance
of these cpus are incredible intel has
done a great job they improve their
efficiency so thank you to apple for
pushing intel thank you for to amd for
pushing intel bringing more competition
back to get intel back on their game and
creating better products for all of us
the consumers now we are going to be
getting a razer laptop with both an i5
version of this in a 15 inch size and
also the i9
we'll see how these perform in chassis
that are similar to the macbook pro and
in real world workloads such as photo
editing we'll have photoshop davinci uh
davinci resolve for video editing and a
lot more tasks if you guys want to see
that so make sure you guys click that
subscribe button above if you want to
see that check out one of those two
great videos right over there this is
max and i'll see you in the next video
[Music]